wirklich lieb von dir dass du den ganzen
weg mit mir zurück ich mach das doch
gerne
außerdem hast du mir ein eis versprochen
ich hoffe nur dass der rucksack
tatsächlich noch da ist sonst habe ich
kein geld mehr für das eis keinen pass
mehr
das war eine katastrophe die tasche ist
bestimmt auch da müsste hochgestellt und
jetzt sagst du ja den berg hoch das
wirke sich das gar nicht drüber
nachdenken schmeißen sie mich vielleicht
aus dem land keine sorgen
das tun sie nicht und nun verstecke ich
nicht bei mir
notfalls im bett
da ist viel platz
ich hoffe wirklich dass sie ihren
verlorenen rucksack wiederfindet für den
ganzen stress anlagen wenn sie
zurückkommt unbedingt ich liebe 17 wir
gar nicht an
komm schon auf dem rückweg immer schnell
bei schloss drachenburg vorbei das haben
wir auf dem hinweg ausgelassen das wird
gefallen
das haben wir in brasilien gar nicht das
ist schon richtig beeindruckend gibt es
dennoch einen könig oder einen
verzauberten prinzen oder so nein
prinzen kannst doch haben prozesse
wenn sie gestatten
ich